.
Wenn Dunkelheit
und Ruhe einkehren ...
... und dem ganzen Land eine ge-
heimnisvolle Schönheit verleihen ...
... wenn die einen bereits schlafen,
erzählen die anderen
ihre Geschichten.
Geschichten, einzigartig
und verborgen, kommen zum Vorschein.
Auf einer Reise
durch die Nächte der Schweiz.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Auf der A2. Ein Schwertransport
auf dem Weg Richtung Gotthard.
Noch ist er einige Kilometer
vom Nordportal des grossen Tunnels
entfernt.
Verantwortlich:
die Kantonspolizei Uri.
Bär Michael, Kantonspolizei Uri.
Hallo?
Hallo,
Polizei Kanton Tessin.
Hallo, salut.
Hallo. Sprechen Sie
ein bisschen französisch?
Nein, leider nicht.
- Nein.
Wir erwarten Sie in Airolo.
- Jawohl.
Ist der Tunnel schon gesperrt?
Ja, wir sind schon hier.
Und ist schon gesperrt?
Der Tunnel?
- Entschuldigung?
Der Gotthardtunnel
ist schon gesperrt?
Ich weiss nicht,
ob es ist aperto o no.
Schon noch ...
- Ich weiss nicht.
Aber ich rufe ...
- Aber wir sind hier und warten.
Ja, sehr gut.
- Okay, danke.
Okay, bis später.
- Bis später. Danke.
Ciao.
Eine typische Konversation
über die Sprachgrenzen hinweg.
Wird schon gut gehen.
Mehr Sorgen macht Michael Bär
das Timing.
Es ist unmöglich, dass wir
um 2 Uhr in Airolo sein können.
Das ist eine Illusion.
Das wird 2.30 Uhr, 3 Uhr.
Bis zu 4.30 m breit, bis 53 m lang
und über 80 t schwer
ist die geladene Fracht.
Bestandteile der neuen
Windkraftanlage auf dem Gotthardpass.
Nervös werde ich erst,
wenn jemand nicht mehr fährt
oder etwas Spezielles passiert.
Wir hatten schon solche Konvois
in die Gegenrichtung,
bei denen plötzlich jemand funkte:
"Ich muss anhalten,
ich habe Ölverlust."
Oder irgendetwas -
eine kaputte Leitung.
Wenn so ein Riesenkonvoi
auf offener Strecke anhalten muss,
dann ...
ist das sicher nicht so angenehm.
Etwas später als geplant,
kurz vor 2.30 Uhr,
erreichen die Lkws
das Nadelöhr des Transports:
das Nordportal des Gotthardtunnels.
Konvoi kann weiterfahren,
trotz Rotlicht.
Ich halte den Verkehr an.
Guten Abend,
Bär von der Kantonspolizei.
Ich wäre froh,
wenn Sie hier warten würden.
Der Tunnel
ist für ca. 20 Min. gesperrt.
Okay?
- Wegen Ausnahmetransporten.
Sie dürfen erst weiterfahren,
wenn es auf Grün wechselt.
Kein Problem.
- Also. Perfekt, vielen Dank.
Können wir hier warten?- Ja.
Über den Pass ist auch schlecht ...
Wieso wird das Grün?
- Auto abstellen?
Ja, Sie können abstellen.
Pannenblinker, da es ein Fahrzeug
ist, aber das ist nicht gut.
Uri EZ von Bär, antworten.
Alle Fahrzeuge müssen warten.
Verstanden.
Warum steht es auf Grün?
In Göschenen. Antworten.
(Funk) Verstanden,
das ist richtig, antworten.
Du musst es auf Rot lassen,
bis wir aus Airolo Bescheid geben.
Jetzt kann der Konvoi
seine Fahrt sicher fortsetzen.
(Männerstimme) Signore e Signori,
benvenuti nella galleria
autostradale del San Gottardo.
Mantenetevi sintonizzati
su questa frequenza,
in modo da ricevere
gli importanti informazioni.
Das Gotthardmassiv.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Rhone, Reuss, Rhein und Ticino
entspringen hier
und fliessen
in alle Himmelsrichtungen,
bis ins Mittelmeer
und in die Nordsee.
In einer klaren Nacht gut sichtbar:
das Schreckhorn im Berner Oberland,
der nördlichste 4'000er Europas.
Die Grimselstaumauer
wird gerade saniert.
19 Min. später.
Ohne Zwischenfall
erreicht der Schwertransportkonvoi
nach 16,9 km das Südportal.
Massarbeit.
Nur wenige Zentimeter bleiben zwi-
schen der Tunneldecke und der Ladung,
den Motorgehäusen der Windkrafträder.
Grazie mille. Buon lavoro. Ciao.
Der anschliessende Anstieg
auf der Gotthard-Passstrasse
ist für alle
eine echte Herausforderung.
Auch für routinierte Chauffeure.
Wir hatten schon diverse Fahrten
hier hoch.
Da kennt man die Chauffeure,
die nun unterwegs sind.
Einige kenne ich schon Jahre.
Wir hatten
schon einige spektakuläre Transporte
oder durften gemeinsam
interessante Sachen durchführen.
So ist dieser Kontakt gewachsen.
Die Windräder auf dem Gotthardpass
werden die grössten in den Alpen sein
und 15 % der landesweiten Windenergie
produzieren.
Insgesamt sechs Haarnadelkurven
müssen noch überwunden werden.
Diese Ausnahmetransporte hier
sind eigentlich die Königsklasse
im Transportgewerbe.
In die Zentralschweiz.
Weit über dem Vierwaldstättersee
strahlt wie eine riesige Lichtleiter
der Hammetschwand Lift.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Mit den Füssen
steht er im Kanton Luzern.
Das Aussichtsplateau des Bürgenstocks
jedoch
gehört bereits zum Kanton Nidwalden.
Der Hof der Familie Zwyssig
auf dem Seelisberg.
Martha Zwyssig
bewirtschaftet den Bio-Hof
gemeinsam mit ihrem Sohn Daniel.
Die Bäuerin
liebt die Arbeit in der Nacht.
Es ist ruhig.
Es ist noch Nacht. Niemand
ist unterwegs, man ist allein.
Das ist schön.
Ursprünglich gehörte der Hof
Marthas Mann.
Seit seinem Tod vor 16 Jahren
trägt sie die Verantwortung.
Gemeinsam mit ihren Kindern
hält sie den Betrieb am Laufen.
Seit sechs Jahren
leitet ihr Sohn den Hof.
Allein hätte ich es
nicht machen können.
Aber mit den Kindern zusammen
ging es gut.
Wir haben noch Schwägerinnen
und Schwager, die aushelfen,
wenn es nötig ist.
Ich habe immer Hilfe bekommen,
das ist schön.
12 Std.
dauert der Arbeitstag von Martha.
Auch an Sonn- und Feiertagen.
Die 15 Kühe
geben ca. 300 l Milch am Tag.
Es rentiert schon,
v.a. weil wir in Seelisberg
einen guten Milchpreis haben.
Mein Sohn
arbeitet daneben noch Teilzeit.
Darum melke ich hier.
Komm, es gibt Frühstück.
Vier Kälber sind derzeit im Stall.
Das jüngste ist gerade fünf Tage alt.
Die Tiere aufwachsen zu sehen
ist für Martha die grösste Freude
an ihrem Beruf.
Sie kennen mich, das ist schön.
Wenn wir auf die Alp gehen und
mit ihnen reden, kennen sie uns.
Das ist schön.
Ich mache es
noch ein bis zwei Jahre.
Es kommt auf die Situation an.
Ich hoffe, er findet eine Frau,
die mithilft.
Dann könnte ich zurückstehen.
Das wäre für mich
eine grosse Erleichterung.
Mein Hobby ist Trachten sticken.
Das habe ich früher oft gemacht.
Das ist in letzter Zeit
oft liegengeblieben.
Das möchte ich machen:
Trachten nähen, Trachten sticken.
Das möchte ich gerne machen.
* Feierliche Klänge *
Die Schweiz aus der Luft
ist gesprenkelt
mit hell erleuchteten,
von Weitem sichtbaren grünen Flächen.
Auf über 10'000 Fussballplätzen
wird mit Flutlicht
trainiert und gespielt.
Absolute Dunkelheit
im Dreieck Thun-Bern-Fribourg -
der Naturpark Gantrisch.
(Frau) Es ist ein sehr heimeliges
Gefühl, hier unterwegs zu sein.
Man hat einen Wahnsinnssternenhimmel
für sich alleine.
Man ist alleine, aber nicht einsam.
Das ist
ein schönes ... schönes Gefühl,
nachts unterwegs zu sein.
Nicole Dahinden untersucht hier
die Lichtverschmutzung.
Dabei helfen ihr
senkrecht in den Nachthimmel
fotografierte Fischaugenaufnahmen.
Gute Werte sind die dunkeln.
Es sind teilweise
beinahe schwarze Punkte darunter.
Wenn auf diesem Bild
die Milchstrasse nicht wäre,
würde man
einen sehr dunklen Himmel sehen.
Hier ist ein Wert von 21,58.
Das ist ziemlich gut.
Perfekt wären 21,8 Magnituden.
In Städten liegen die Werte
wegen der Lichtverschmutzung
nur zwischen 16 und 19.
Man sieht hier die Gantrischkette.
Das ist im Süden.
Im Norden ist Bern,
aber das ist stark abgeschirmt
von diesem Hügelzug.
Man sieht hier auch die Bäume.
Man sieht auch hier die Lichtver-
schmutzung von Thun her, im Osten.
Und auch hier sieht man einen
kleinen rot-gelben Ausschlag,
der von Westen her kommt.
Das ist bereits von der Westschweiz,
vom Kanton Fribourg.
Wir möchten, dass sich die Nacht
wieder viel stärker ausbreitet,
dass sich die Dunkelheit
wieder stärker ausbreitet
und das Licht zurückdrängt.
Der Gurnigel, ein Hügelzug,
gilt im Naturpark Gantrisch
weltweit als einer der zehn
besten Orte, um Sterne zu beobachten.
Wow, so habe ich den noch selten
gesehen. Das ist wirklich genial.
Auch Hobbyastronom Stefan Meister
kommt seit Jahren hierher.
Heute bietet der Saturn
mit seinen Ringen
ein ganz besonderes Spektakel.
Jetzt sieht man
die beiden Ringe sehr schön,
die getrennt sind.
Man sieht ausserdem ...
... die Struktur der Wolken
auf dem Saturn.
Das leichte Flimmern
ist die Luft, durch die wir schauen.
So ruhig und so absolut scharf -
unglaublich.
Ich beobachte seit etwa 40 Jahren.
Das ist
bisher zwei-, dreimal passiert,
dass es so perfekt war.
Wahnsinn. Genial.
Mit seinem selbstgebauten Teleskop
wirkt auch der hellste Stern
am Himmel zum Greifen nah.
Die Venus, 40 Mio. km entfernt.
Innerhalb eines halben Jahres
entstand das bei mir
im Keller und in der Küche.
Mit Drehbank und Säge und Oberfräse.
Es besteht aus Holz und Metall,
mit einer
etwas speziellen Montierung.
Aber in dieser Montierung
gibt es keine Elektronik.
Das ist alles manuell. Ich kann
das Fernrohr von Hand bewegen.
Es ist zwar 30 kg schwer,
aber ich kann
es mit dem kleinen Finger bewegen,
als würde es auf Butter laufen.
Die grossen Waldflächen um die ehe-
malige Panzerplattform Stierenhütte
erlauben einen nahezu
ungetrübten Blick in die Nacht.
Nicole Dahinden
setzt sich seit Jahren
für die Bewahrung
des dunklen Nachhimmels ein.
Man muss darauf achten,
wo und wie man beleuchtet,
und zu welchem Zweck.
Man soll nicht einfach Licht machen,
wo man gerade Lust hat,
sondern
ein bisschen nachhaltig überlegen:
Wofür brauche ich dieses Licht?
Brauche ich es wirklich
und in dieser Intensität?
Für welchen Zweck
brauche ich überhaupt Licht?
Bei Dunkelheit und klarer Sicht
kann der Mensch etwa 6'500 Sterne
mit blossem Auge erkennen.
Zu diesem Sternenhimmel,
den jeder Mensch auf der Welt
sehen können müsste,
sind so viele Gedanken entstanden,
so viele ... Gedichte,
und so viel Kunstvolles,
so viele Bilder
sind auch in der Nacht entstanden.
Das finde ich etwas Schönes: alleine
unter dem Sternenhimmel zu sein.
Es ist ein Fenster zum All, zu
dieser Leere oder zum vollen All.
Das ist total spannend.
* Beschauliche, glockige Klänge *
Weiter gegen Westen.
Die Poyabrücke
ist die neueste Brücke in Fribourg.
Ganz der Brückenbautradition
der Stadt verpflichtet,
ist auch sie eine Hängebrücke.
Noch älter als das Schloss Gruyère
aus dem 13. Jh.
ist der berühmte Käse.
Der wurde erstmals 1115
in einer Urkunde des ersten Grafen
von Greyerz erwähnt.
Am Fusse des Moléson
funkeln sie bereits in der Ferne -
die Lichter des Genfersees.
Wenn die Zugvögel
Richtung Südwesten fliegen,
zieht es den Ornithologen
Lionel Maumary und sein Team
in die Berge bei Montreux.
Mit Netzen wollen sie
die durchreisenden Vögel einfangen.
Heute hilft ihm
Martine Wagen-Jaussy aus dem Jura.
Tu me donnes un sac?
Der Trauerschnäpper
ist bereits der dritte Vogel,
den sie heute Nacht fangen.
Schon früh hat Lionel
seine Liebe zu Vögeln entdeckt.
Als andere Kinder damals
Kröten aufbliesen, sagt er,
habe er als Sechsjähriger
ein Rotkehlchen gezähmt.
Bis heute hat er mehr als
350 Vogelarten untersucht.
Je l'ai posé. Et il est parti.
* Sanfte Musik *
Über drei Hügel
erstreckt sich Lausanne.
Das herausragende Bauwerk der Stadt:
die Kathedrale Notre-Dame.
Von ihrem Turm aus
ruft der Nachtwächter
immer zur vollen Stunde die Uhrzeit
in die vier Himmelsrichtungen.
* Ausruf auf Französisch *
* Dumpfe Klänge *
Dieser Porsche Cayenne
kostet in einfachster Ausführung
über 100'000 Fr.
Dank der Graffitys von Sprayer Baro
ist er ein Unikat.
Und unverkäuflich.
Neben dem Porsche besitzt Baro
auch einen von innen und aussen
besprayten Bentley.
Heute Nacht führt Baro
eine Auftragsarbeit
in der Lausanner Innenstadt aus.
Sein Sprayerkollege Ludovic Ludo
hilft ihm dabei.
* Der Generator brummt laut. *
Dank der Lärmdämmung
können die beiden Graffiti-Künstler
die ganze Nacht durcharbeiten,
ohne die Nachbarn zu stören.
Seine ersten Sprayversuche
unternahm Baro als Jugendlicher.
Am Anfang hat Baro
nachts Züge besprayt.
Er wurde erwischt
und musste sich in einer Fabrik
das Geld für die hohe Busse
verdienen.
Jetzt kann er vom Sprayen leben.
"Während ihr schlaft" - das ist auch
der Titel seines neuesten Werks.
Inzwischen bekommt er Aufträge
aus dem In- und Ausland.
Ici, dans la couette.
- Oui, oui.
Mais moi, je disais de le faire ...
- Au dessus.
Là, tout petit, le bâton de merde.
Il faut qu'il soit
dans le même style.
* Sanfte Musik *
Von Lausanne bis Genf
sind es nur knapp 70 km.
Die meistbefahrene Bahnstrecke
der Romandie.
Höhere Geschwindigkeit
und schnellerer Taktfahrplan
sollen das Bahnfahren
noch attraktiver machen.
Deshalb wird in dieser Nacht
in Genève-Sécheron,
nördlich des Genfer Hauptbahnhofs,
gearbeitet.
Chelso Pereira ist seit 2014 bei
den CFF als Maitre de voies ferrées.
Die alten Schwellen und Schienen
müssen raus
und der Schotter erneuert werden.
Am Tag
wären diese Arbeiten undenkbar,
denn auf dem Nebengleis
läuft der Zugverkehr weiter.
Knapp drei Wochen
sind für die Arbeiten
an der Bahnhofseinfahrt vorgesehen.
Das bedeutet für die Männer
weiterhin Nachtschichten,
von 20 Uhr abends bis 4 Uhr morgens.
* Sanfte Musik *
Genf, die internationalste Stadt
der Schweiz.
Ihr Wahrzeichen, der berühmte
Springbrunnen Jet d'eau,
ist in den Wintermonaten
nur tagsüber in Betrieb.
Über 100 internationale
Organisationen haben ihren Sitz hier,
u.a. auch die UNO.
* Sanfte Streicherklänge *
Auch der Arbeitstag
von Jérémy und Frédéric Clerc
beginnt in der Dunkelheit.
Von Prangins aus fahren die Fischer
jeden Nacht hinaus auf den See.
GPS-Daten weisen ihnen den Weg.
(Französisch)
Die Clercs sind v.a. auf Felchen aus.
Die dürfen nur zwischen 3
und 10 Uhr morgens gefischt werden.
Deshalb müssen Vater und Sohn
so früh raus,
um ihren Kunden
frische Ware liefern zu können.
Während der Laichzeit
dürfen die Fischer
drei Monate lang
keine Felchen fangen.
Mutterschaftsurlaub
nennt Frédéric das scherzhaft.
Jetzt haben sich die Bestände
wieder erholt.
Frühmorgens die Netze einholen,
sie am Abend wieder auswerfen.
Die Arbeitstage von Frédéric
und Jérémy Clerc sind lang.
Doch etwas anderes zu machen,
kommt für sie nicht infrage.
Montreux,
die Côte d'Azur der Schweiz.
Bekannt für seine Luxushotels
und fürs Jazzfestival.
Der Brand des Kasinos 1971
inspirierte die Rockband Deep Purple
zu ihrem Welthit
"Smoke on the Water".
Gegen Norden im Waadtländer Jura
Wenn die Temperaturen
am niedrigsten sind,
herrschen für ihr Vorhaben
ideale Bedingungen.
Fabian Jobin und Arthur Gremaud
wollen Rehkitze vor dem Tod
durch Mähmaschinen bewahren.
Salut!
Unterstützt werden die beiden
heute früh von zwei Jägern.
C'est celui que tu as vu,
là au fond?
Ihre Drohne ist mit einer
Wärmebildkamera ausgestattet.
Damit will Fabian
die Tiere aufspüren.
Jäger Zacchari Pasquier
soll sie dann aus dem Feld tragen.
Schon am Vortag waren die Jäger hier
und haben ein paar Kitze entdeckt.
Die wollen sie jetzt finden.
Et puis,
là il va aller jusqu'au bout ...
Vraiment, jusque là au coin.
Eine Fläche so gross
wie eineinhalb Fussballfelder
sucht die Drohne in nur 5 Min. ab.
Die meisten Rehkitze
findet man im Sommer,
doch auch im Herbst entdeckt man
immer wieder einzelne Tiere.
Bei jedem dieser gelben Punkte
könnte es sich um ein Rehkitz handeln
oder um andere Wildtiere
wie Hasen, Vögel oder Wildschweine.
Diesmal ist es nur ein Hase.
Die Fläche ist rehfrei
und kann gemäht werden.
Yverdon am Ufer des Neuenburgersees
* Sanfte Klänge *
Farbenfroh weist nachts
die Banque Cantonale Neuchâteloise
den Weg zu den Häfen.
Am anderen Ende des Sees
thront das Schloss Neuenburg
gemeinsam mit der Kollegiatskirche
auf einem Felsen über der Stadt.
* Pulsierende Musik *
Wie aus dem Nichts
taucht sie plötzlich auf:
die Raffinerie Cressier
zwischen Neuenburger- und Bielersee.
Sie ist die einzige Erdölraffinerie
der Schweiz
und wird durch eine Pipeline
aus der Nähe von Marseille beliefert.
Cressier produziert etwa ein Viertel
aller Mineralölprodukte des Landes.
* Spannende Klänge *
Im Emmental brennt nur
auf wenigen Höfen Licht.
Einer davon ist Ranbühl.
* Leise, beschwingte Klänge *
Da ist mehr Butter drin
als in einem normalen Zopf.
Theres Steiner und ihre Tochter Anita
backen fünf verschiedene Sorten Brot.
Und aufs Wochenende hin
Sonntagszöpfe, ihre Spezialität.
Die ganze Nacht
stehen sie in der Backstube.
Ich kann zu jeder Tages-
und Nachtzeit aufstehen,
das spielt für mich keine Rolle.
Die jüngste Tochter
ist gelernte Bäckerin-Konditorin.
Ich habe sie am Morgen
immer aus dem Haus gehen hören.
Um 2, 3, 4 Uhr.
Auch jetzt
brauche ich keinen Wecker.
Ich wache ...
Ab 4 Uhr bin ich eigentlich wach -
oder ab 4.30, 5 Uhr.
Für mich ist das kein Opfer,
ausser dass ich
etwas weniger Schlaf bekomme.
Aber ich helfe gerne ab und zu aus.
Es ist nicht jedes Mal,
dass ich helfen muss - oder darf.
Hauptsächlich kümmert sich Anita
um den heimischen Hof.
In der Backstube ihrer Mutter
arbeitet sie in Teilzeit.
Theres hat schon immer gern gebacken.
Vor 16 Jahren hat ihr Mann für sie
eine eigene Backstube eingerichtet.
* Hohler Klang *
Klingt gut.
- Ja.
Gut, oder?
So teste ich,
ob der Zopf fertig gebacken ist.
Je hohler er klingt,
desto besser durch ist er.
Bei Mutter habe ich gelernt,
dass man so überprüft,
ob er lange genug im Ofen war.
* Hohler Klang *
Die Brote und Sonntagszöpfe
sind für den Bauernmarkt
in der Berner Münstergasse bestimmt.
Meist sind sie schnell ausverkauft.
Das ist eine Herausforderung.
Ich weiss es nie im Voraus.
Wetterbericht hören - wird es schön?
Für Sonntag sind Gewitter
in den Bergen gemeldet,
da gehen wohl nicht alle wandern.
Entsprechend backe ich -
mal mehr, mal weniger.
Es ist unterschiedlich.
Wir hatten auch schon
um 10 Uhr keine Zöpfe mehr.
Aber sonst geht es auf,
so bis 11.30 Uhr.
Dann hat man noch ein paar Brote
und etwas Süsses.
Das kann man dann bis 12.15,
12.30 Uhr auch noch verkaufen.
Das ist ... gut.
Mehl, Salz und Zucker mischen,
Hefe zerbröckeln, daruntermischen.
Butter mit der Milch beigeben,
mischen
und zu einem weichen, glatten Teig
kneten.
Am Ende ist er 5 kg schwer,
der grösste Zopf der Steiners.
Das Rezept verrate ich nicht.
Das ist ein uraltes Rezept
der Mutter meiner Mutter.
Ich habe gesagt,
das verrate ich nicht.
So sind diese Rezepte
halt Geheimnisse.
Wie sie backen kann ich nicht,
das kriege ich nicht hin.
Nach all den Jahren nicht.
Manchmal rufe ich an:
"Wie geht das?"
Sie sagt mir,
wie viel sie wovon nimmt
und: "Dann musst du halt schauen."
Also.
Es reicht gerade noch
für eine kleine Pause,
bevor sie los muss nach Bern.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Nur gerade 143'000 Einwohner
zählt die Bundeshauptstadt.
Das Münster wurde
bis auf den oberen Teil des Turms
komplett aus Berner Sandstein erbaut.
Und um das ganze Land
zu repräsentieren,
wurden im Bundeshaus
nahezu alle in der Schweiz vor-
kommenden Gesteinssorten verwendet.
Die A1 verbindet
die West- mit der Ostschweiz.
Mit 410 km
die längste Autobahn des Landes.
Verkehrstechnisch günstig gelegen:
das Shoppyland,
die Gegend um das Autobahnkreuz
Schönbühl.
* Dunkle, pulsierende Klänge *
Am Südfuss des Jura: Solothurn.
Barockstadt und dank
der Film- und Literaturtage
wichtiges Kulturzentrum.
33 kg wiegt die riesige
feuervergoldete Kupferkugel,
die den Turm der St. Ursen-Kathedrale
krönt.
Am Ufer der Aare, auf dem Gelände
einer ehemaligen Zellulosefabrik,
befindet sich das Attisholz-Areal.
Heute wird es
als Kulturtreffpunkt genutzt.
Bis 2040 soll hier
ein Generationenprojekt zum Wohnen,
Arbeiten und Leben für
mehrere Tausend Menschen entstehen.
Der Weissenstein,
der Hausberg der Stadt
und Heimat für die Jäger der Nacht.
Im Nidleloch,
einem weitverzweigten Höhlensystem,
das bis zu 407 m in die Tiefe führt,
finden Fledermäuse
einen perfekten Rückzugsort.
Mit der sog. Harfenfalle fängt
Biologe Elias Bader die Säugetiere.
Eine Harfenfalle funktioniert
nach einem ganz einfachen Prinzip.
Sie besteht aus zwei
mit Nylonfäden bespannten Rahmen.
Wenn eine Fledermaus zur Höhle
hinein- oder hinausfliegt,
muss sie zwischen den Fäden
durchfliegen.
Das tut sie,
indem sie sich so aufstellt
oder die Flügel zusammenfaltet.
Sie fliegt hindurch und muss
danach die Flügel wieder ausbreiten.
Sie hat vor dem zweiten Rahmen
nicht genügend Zeit, zu reagieren,
bleibt dort hängen
und fällt in die Auffangtasche.
Fledermäuse machen in der Schweiz
rund ein Drittel
aller Säugetierarten aus.
Bechsteinfledermaus.
* Klickern *
Männchen.
Adult.
Elias Bader und Katja Rauchenstein
erforschen dieses einzige Säugetier,
das fliegen kann.
Unterarmlänge: 44,3.
Wir kamen zum Schluss:
Die sog. Ökosystemdienstleistungen,
die die Fledermäuse in der Schweiz
für die Menschen erbringen,
würden einem Geldbetrag zwischen
einem dreistelligen Millionen-
und einem tiefen Milliardenbetrag
pro Jahr entsprechen.
Eine knappe Milliarde.
Das haben die Forscher berechnet.
So gross
wäre der Verlust der Landwirte,
würden die Fledermäuse
nicht Nacht für Nacht Insekten jagen.
* Knistern *
Zwergfledermaus.
- Sind auch dabei.
Biologin Katja Rauchenstein
hat ihre Masterarbeit
über Fledermäuse geschrieben.
Dieses Gerät bringt die Rufe
in den für uns hörbaren Bereich.
So können wir sie hören.
Wir gehören gerade
eine Zwergfledermaus,
die um uns herumschwirrt.
Viele Arten kann man
anhand der Rufe unterscheiden.
Insgesamt
27 verschiedene Fledermausarten
wurden im Jura bereits gesichtet.
Bis zu 8 Std.
verbringen Katja und Elias
nachts gemeinsam in der Karsthöhle.
Es ist sicher wichtig,
dass man sich versteht.
Man ist die ganze Nacht
gemeinsam draussen.
Es ist auch sehr wichtig,
die Abläufe zu kennen,
zu wissen, was man
in welcher Reihenfolge macht.
Dass die Handgriffe sitzen,
alles bereit liegt,
damit man die Fledermäuse
so kurz wie möglich festhält
und so schnell wie möglich
wieder fliegen lässt.
Einerseits ist es alleine
ziemlich anstrengend,
besonders, wenn es viele Fledermäuse
sind. Da rotiert man alleine.
Andererseits
ist es auch etwas langweilig,
wenn man 6 Std.
alleine im dunkeln Wald sitzt.
Besonders wenn mal nichts läuft.
Wenn man 6 Std. auf seinem Stühlchen
wartet, dass etwas passiert,
ist es angenehmer,
Gesellschaft zu haben.
* Hohes Klickern *
* Ruhige Klänge *
Wo die Nord-Süd- und die
Ost-West-Achsen aufeinandertreffen:
das Autobahnkreuz Härkingen.
Praktisch alle Pakete
für das Mittelland landen hier:
im grössten Postpaketzentrum.
Jede Nacht werden 400'000 Pakete an
die zuständigen Postämter verteilt.
Fast zwei Drittel davon
werden über die Schiene in
alle Himmelsrichtungen transportiert.
Gegen Norden, zur Grenze hin:
der Grossraum Basel.
Einige Agglomerationsgemeinden gehö-
ren zu Frankreich und Deutschland.
Viele der über 800'000 Einwohner
arbeiten darum als Grenzgänger
in der Metropole.
Basel als weltweit führendes Zentrum
der Chemie- und Pharmaindustrie
demonstriert dies
mit Roche Tower 1 und 2 eindrücklich.
Die beiden Türme
der Architekten Herzog & de Meuron
überragen die Altstadt
um das Zehnfache.
Pläne für einen dritten,
noch höheren Turm liegen vor.
Von der Mittleren Rheinbrücke abwärts
gilt der Rhein
als internationales Gewässer
und sichert der Schweiz über
Rotterdam den Zugang zur Nordsee.
* Applaus, jazzige Klänge *
Anfangs war das Musikfestival
IMFLUSS sehr umstritten.
Einige Anwohner zogen sogar bis vor
Bundesgericht, um es zu verbieten.
Heute ist es aus dem Basler Sommer
nicht mehr wegzudenken.
* Jubel *
Am Dreiländereck
befinden sich die Rheinhäfen.
Umschlagplatz
für Waren aus aller Welt.
Fabio, die Nummer ist: UHCU 377-9.
Kannst du dann als Nächstes bringen.
Die Grenzgänger Fabio Piraino und Tim
Hebestreit haben bald Schichtende.
Fabio wohnt in Frankreich,
Tim in Deutschland.
Unser schöner Künz-Kran,
der grösste in der Schweiz, 700 t,
hat richtig Kraft
und in der Nacht
ist er am schönsten.
Hier werden jährlich
6-7 Mio. t Güter umgeschlagen.
Fabio geniesst es,
alleine so weit oben.
Die Aussicht ist schön.
Man kann hier Basel sehen.
Ab und zu kommen ein paar Schiffe.
Für das Feuerwerk
hat man hier die beste Aussicht.
Man sieht wirklich alles.
Die Anbindung des Rheins
an das Strassennetz
und die Schienen der SBB Cargo
ist die Drehscheibe
zwischen den Seehäfen
Rotterdam und Genua.
Im Schiff, beim Lkw und beim Zug -
abladen, laden - muss man
wirklich sehr genau arbeiten.
Wir reden hier von Millimeterarbeit.
Wenn man das Gefühl dafür nicht hat,
ist man für diesen Beruf
nicht geschaffen.
Jeder vierte Container des Landes
wird über diese Terminals
abgewickelt.
Fabio macht das seit 15 Jahren.
Höhenkoller kennt er nicht.
Wir haben schon viele gehabt, die
nach 5 Min. wieder runter mussten.
Es ist echt nicht für jedermann,
hier oben zu sitzen.
Man schaut die ganze Zeit runter,
die Kabine wackelt.
Ich bin schwindelfrei,
mir dreht auch der Kopf nicht.
Ich gehe gerne auf Karussells
und so.
Ich hatte damit noch nie Probleme.
Fabio arbeitet im Schichtbetrieb.
Genauso wie Tim.
Die Nacht ist einfach am tollsten.
Da komme ich voll aus mir raus,
kann ein bisschen Chef spielen.
Ja, Nachtschicht ist ...
... schon eine geile Arbeit.
Aber das Privatleben
leidet manchmal schon.
Wenn man Frau oder Kinder hat,
ist es schwierig.
Man geht nachts aus dem Haus,
die Kinder am Morgen zur Schule.
Man kommt am Morgen nach Hause,
sieht die Kinder nicht.
Die Frau geht zur Arbeit.
Die Frau oder Freundin muss viel
Verständnis haben für diesen Beruf.
Schichtende.
Zeit, den Kran zu parkieren.
Noch ein Stück.
Halt.
Ich mach den Verschluss zu.
Du kannst Feierabend machen. Super
Tag, wir haben alles geschafft.
Das Mittelland.
Die riesige Dampfwolke
des Kernkraftwerks Gösgen
ist auch in der Nacht
von Weitem sichtbar.
Gösgen ist eines von drei
Kernkraftwerken im Schweizer Netz.
Der Druckwasserreaktor erzeugt etwa
ein Drittel des Schweizer Atomstroms.
Mitten im Aargau
über der Ebene und der A1:
das Schloss Lenzburg,
eine der ältesten Höhenburgen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Staufer, Kyburger und Habsburger
lebten darin.
Und während der beiden Kappelerkriege
vor 500 Jahren
diente es den Reformierten
als Operationsbasis.
Mehr einer
nach innen gerichteten Festung
gleicht die Strafanstalt Lenzburg.
In der geschlossenen Abteilung sind
ausschliesslich Männer inhaftiert.
Wie die Insekten das Licht,
so umkreisen die Autos
die Autobahnkreuze
und Auffahrten des Mittellandes.
Sempach im Kanton Luzern.
Insektenforscherin Eva Knop
ist auf der Pirsch.
Wenn man nachts arbeitet, darf man
keinen Ekel vor Insekten haben,
weil man tatsächlich weniger sieht.
Aber wir möchten natürlich
mit möglichst wenig Licht arbeiten.
Man schätzt, dass über die Hälfte
aller Tiere, die es gibt,
nachtaktiv sind.
Gleichzeitig weiss man fast nichts
darüber, was nachts passiert.
V.a. was kleine wirbellose Tiere
betrifft.
Willst du die Grossen rausnehmen?
Neben dem Netz nutzt die Entomologin
spezielle Lichtfallen,
um die wirbellosen Tiere anzulocken.
Heute Nacht hilft ihr
die Studentin Majken Grimm.
Nehmen wir noch diese Fliege?
Dann haben wir alle.
Ja, und den Rest
kriegen wir beim Leeren.
Es ist sehr wichtig,
dass wir das System nicht stören.
Die meisten Insekten,
die nachts aktiv sind,
reagieren extrem schnell auf Licht.
Es dauert dann relativ lange,
bis sie sich
von diesem Lichtschock erholen.
Es gibt Schätzungen von etwa 1 Std.
Insgesamt gibt es über 20'000
Insektenarten in der Schweiz.
Etwa die Hälfte von ihnen
ist nachtaktiv.
Demgegenüber stehen
gerade mal 100 Säugetierarten.
Trotzdem bedauern
die Wissenschaftlerinnen
jedes Tier,
das für ihre Forschung sterben muss.
Spannend. Es gab richtig viele.
Hummeln, Nachtfalter.
Wespe. Fliege.
Eeine tote Hummel in der Falle
ist nicht schön.
Aber es ist leider
bei Insekten nicht möglich,
sie anders zu bestimmen.
Man muss sie
in den meisten Fällen umbringen
und dann genau anschauen.
Dank Feldforschung
konnten Eva und ihr Team nachweisen,
dass Insekten nachts
künstlich beleuchtete Blüten meiden
und nicht befruchten.
Die Folgen sind geringere Ernten.
Einerseits ist die Atmosphäre
nachts ganz anders als tagsüber.
Es ist eine unentdeckte Welt, oder
zum grossen Teil unentdeckte Welt.
Das gibt es nicht mehr so oft
in der Ökologie:
Gebiete,
die noch völlig unerforscht sind
und diesen Zauber haben,
dass man nicht wirklich weiss,
was dort läuft.
Du siehst hier das Radargerät.
Ornithologe Felix Liechti.
Er setzt modernste Technik ein:
ein Radargerät.
Damit beobachtet er das
nächtliche Zugverhalten von Vögeln
und anderen Tieren.
Dies im Auftrag der Universität Bern
und der Vogelwarte Sempach.
Sind das alles Insekten?
Du kannst da unten
die roten Kreuze sehen.
Das sind alles Insekten.
Das ist der Verlauf des Abends
vom Radar aus gesehen,
wenn die Insekten kommen.
Das ist vor der Dämmerung.
Es gibt noch fast keine Insekten.
Das ist eine
relativ durchschnittliche Nacht.
Hier ist eine andere Nacht.
Da sind jetzt ganz viele Insekten.
Fast so viele wie am Tag.
Wohin und warum
bewegen sich Insekten nachts?
Wie beeinflusst Licht
diese Bewegungen?
Diese Fragen wollen die Forscher
mithilfe der Radaraufnahmen
beantworten.
Als wir es noch manuell machten,
konzentrierten wir uns auf die Vögel
und beachteten die Millionen
von Echos der Insekten nicht.
Doch mit der automatischen Aus-
wertung hat man es sofort zur Hand.
Man kann sehr gute Auswertungen
machen und damit arbeiten.
Es ist für einen Ornithologen
faszinierend,
das Vogelfutter zu untersuchen.
Weiter östlich:
Zug ist Dank seiner
wirtschaftsfreundlichen Steuerpolitik
heute der wohlhabendste Kanton
der Schweiz.
* Lockere Musik *
Fast 35'000 Firmen
haben ihren Sitz hier.
Eine Grosszahl
von internationalen Pharmaunternehmen
unterhält Niederlassungen
und Forschungseinrichtungen.
Neben Industrie und Handel
spielt aber auch
die Landwirtschaft eine Rolle.
Bis spät in die Nacht wird die
letzte Ernte des Jahres eingefahren.
Gegen Norden: der Flughafen Zürich.
Kurz vor 23 Uhr
ist die letzte Maschine gelandet.
Im Kontrollfahrzeug Gusti 1
beginnt Rolf Wallner seine Schicht.
Bei ihm laufen alle Fäden
der Pistenkontrolle zusammen.
Eugen 11, du kannst raus.
* Klingeln *
Airport Authority, Wallner.
Sind die Regeln,
die Vorgaben eingehalten?
Stehen Sachen herum,
die weggeblasen werden könnten?
Das müssen wir wissen,
das müssen wir uns anschauen.
Und darum rufen sie uns an,
Tag und Nacht.
Der Nachtwächter des Flughafens
verantwortet
den kompletten Aussenbereich.
Insbesondere
die Start- und Landebahnen.
Mit Trockeneis
reinigen die Elektriker
Lorenzo Gomez und Michael Walser
die Leuchtfeuer der Piste 16.
Hey, Lorenzo.
- Hallo, Rolf.
Wir machen die Piste fertig,
danach können wir
mit der Messung anfangen.
Okay.
Tipptopp. Wir geben dir Bescheid,
sobald wir so weit sind.
Danke.
- Super.
Ciao, Rolf.
Die Lichtmessung ist wichtig.
Defekte Lampen
gefährden den Flugbetrieb.
(Funk)
Ich schalte euch die 16 auf 100 %.
Super. Vielen Dank.
Jetzt lassen sich
die einzelnen Lampen
mit blossem Auge
nicht mehr unterscheiden.
Dafür braucht es einen Filter.
Die Leuchtfeuer der grössten Piste
des Zürcher Flughafens
sind für die Piloten bei klarer Sicht
schon von Deutschland aus zu sehen -
30 km vor der Landung.
Mehr links.
Perfekt, super. So passt es.
Kommt jemand von rechts?
Ist alles frei.
Pistenkreuzung ist gut.
Mit diesem Augenschutz sehe ich nur
die einzelnen Lichtpunkte am Boden
und vielleicht
knapp 10 m von der Piste.
Ich kann nicht genau bestimmen,
ob es die Pistenbefeuerung
oder ein anderes Fahrzeug ist
Noch 100 m.
Michi als Beifahrer
hat viel bessere Sicht
und kann mich rechtzeitig warnen.
30.
20.
10.
Und ...
... stopp!
Defekte oder lichtschwache Lampen
werden sofort ausgewechselt.
Ob Starkstrom, mittlere Spannungen
oder Schwachstrom,
die beiden Elektriker
haben jede Nacht zu tun.
Den Flughafen erlebt man nie
so ruhig wie in der Nacht.
Wir sind nur wenige Personen,
die das hier erleben dürfen.
Es ist etwas Besonderes, wenn man
sich auf der Piste bewegen darf.
Geschafft.
Zeit für die finale Kontrollfahrt.
Turm, Gusti 1, guten Morgen.
Rollweg Echo 9.
Kann ich auf Piste 16?
Gusti 1, Turm, du kannst
von Rollweg Echo 9 auf Piste 16.
Turm, Gusti 1 geht
Rolf Wallner hat das letzte Wort.
Nur er darf die Startbahn freigeben.
Ich schaue, ob alles sauber ist,
ob alle Lampen leuchten.
Wenn es Bauarbeiten gab,
schaue ich, ob Dreck rumliegt.
Es lagen schon
Pickel oder Zangen rum.
Die sehe ich und nehme sie weg.
Und wenn alles gut ist,
bin ich der Letzte auf der Piste,
bevor der Flugbetrieb losgeht.
Überspitzt gesagt:
Ich rette jeden Tag
Tausenden von Menschen das Leben,
wenn ich meinen Job richtig mache.
Wie gesagt,
das ist überspitzt gesagt.
Turm,
Gusti 1 ist weg vom Pistensystem.
Rollweg Echo 6 alles gut.
Danke für die Zusammenarbeit.
Schlaf gut, schönen Tag.
In wenigen Stunden,
pünktlich um 6 Uhr,
wird die erste Maschine
Zürich in Richtung Athen verlassen.
Nur einen Katzensprung
vom Flughafen entfernt:
die kleine Weltstadt
und das Finanzzentrum Zürich.
Mitten im Stadtzentrum
der Hauptbahnhof.
Das Schweizer ÖV-Netz
ist eins der dichtesten der Welt.
Gleise prägen das gesamte Stadtbild.
Die meisten Bahnlinien
führen direkt am Toni-Areal vorbei.
Die ehemalige Milchfabrik beherbergt
heute die Hochschule der Künste.
* Sanfte Musik *
Haltestelle für viele S-Bahnen
aus der Agglomeration:
der Bahnhof Zürich Hardbrücke.
Im Sportzentrum Heuried
kündigt sich bereits der Winter an.
Limmatquai, Nieder- und Oberdorf.
Weit über die Landesgrenzen hinaus
bekannt:
die Eidgenössische
Technische Hochschule ETH.
Das Bellevue.
* Lockere, elektronische Musik *
Auf dem Platz vor der Oper
geniessen die Menschen
die letzten warmen Abende.
Weiter seeaufwärts:
die geordnete Welt des
Schweizer Architekten Le Corbusier.
Der Rheinfall bei Schaffhausen.
Hier stürzen pro Sekunde
je nach Jahreszeit
500'000 l Wasser
die 23 m hohen Felsen hinunter.
Der Sage nach
sieht man in mondhellen Nächten
oft ein nebelhaftes Schifflein
mit einem Fährmann
zwischen dem Doppelriff
des Rheinfalls hinabgleiten
und in den milchweissen,
überschäumenden Fluten verschwinden.
* Sanfte, tragende Musik *
Rheinaufwärts zum Bodensee.
Etwa ein Drittel des Sees
gehört zur Schweiz.
Der Romanshorner Hafen
ist der grösste am Bodensee
und Heimathafen der Bodenseefähre.
Von hier aus überquert die Fähre
den See an seiner breitesten Stelle.
Der Bodensee hat seine Tücken.
See-Nebel fordert immer wieder Opfer:
Über 300 Wracks liegen auf dem Grund.
* Sanfte, tragende Musik *
Nicht weit entfernt
im Kanton Thurgau:
Schlafen unter freiem Himmel
auf dem Bio-Hof.
* Kuhglocken, Grillenzirpen *
Falls ihr mitten in der Nacht
noch eine Flasche Wein wollt
oder eine Gutenachtgeschichte
oder so, einfach anrufen.
Ich bin 24 Std. euer Butler.
Renata und Silvius Breitenfeld
haben heute Nacht
das Rundum-Sorglos-Paket
im Null-Sterne-Hotel gebucht.
Mich reizen die Sterne,
und ich hoffe,
wenn das Feuer aus ist,
werden richtig viele zu sehen sein.
Ja, das gibt eine gute Glut.
Die Kleiderordnung für den Butler
ist streng.
Weisses Hemd, weisse Handschuhe,
schwarze Fliege.
Unterhalb des Gürtels
ist die Kleiderwahl jedoch frei.
Das Outfit gehört einfach
zu dem Hotelservice, den wir bieten.
Auch wenn das Hotel auf dem Land
ist, auf einem Bauernhof.
Es ist wie ein Kostüm für mich.
Ich sage immer als Witz,
das ist mein Clownkostüm.
Das ziehe ich an
und bediene so die Gäste.
Aber praktisch ist es nicht.
Auf dem Bauernhof
trägt niemand weisse Handschuhe,
eine Fliege,
und das weisse Hemd
wird schnell dreckig.
Die Handschuhe
muss ich jeden Tag waschen.
Die Betten werden gut gebucht,
Gäste kommen aus der ganzen Welt.
Hier habt ihr noch ein Wasser.
Wenn man Kind ist, möchte man gerne
unter den Sternen schlafen.
Das war mein Traum als Kind.
Einfach schlafen,
dann die Augen öffnen
und die Sterne sehen.
Sollte es heute Nacht doch regnen,
können die Gäste
in einen sog. Back-up-Room
ins Bauernhaus flüchten.
Dort ist auch eine Toilette.
Die meisten schlafen nicht gut, weil
sie mehrmals in der Nacht aufwachen,
wegen des Windes,
der Kuhglocken usw.
Aber es ist einfach ein Erlebnis.
* Sanfte Musik *
Der König der Ostschweiz:
der Säntis.
Hier grenzen drei Kantone aneinander,
die beiden Appenzell
und der Kanton St. Gallen.
In den Alpen ist es Winter.
Der Corvatsch im Scheinwerferlicht.
Eigentlich arbeitet Mariella
auf dem Hof der Eltern.
Doch im Winter
gibt es dort weniger zu tun
und so präpariert sie
die Pisten des Skigebiets.
Es ist bereits ihre elfte Saison.
Ich wollte eigentlich nicht
Pistenbullyfahrerin werden.
Ich wollte nur einmal mitfahren,
weil mich Maschinen faszinieren.
Ich hätte es mir gar nicht
zugetraut, selber zu fahren.
Der damalige Chef,
der mit mitgenommen hat, fand,
ich solle fahren.
Erst weigerte ich mich.
Aber er sagte,
ich fahre ja auch andere Maschinen.
Also probierte ich es,
und da packte mich das Fieber.
"Helden der Nacht"
werden die Bullyfahrer genannt.
Am Corvatsch präparieren sie
jede Nacht 56 Pistenkilometer.
Für mich ist es ein Nebenverdienst,
aber es ist auch eine Leidenschaft.
Ich könnte auch etwas Einfacheres
machen und tagsüber arbeiten,
aber ich bevorzuge die Nachtarbeit.
Unten im Tal: St. Moritz.
* Sanfte Musik *
Sie war die erste Gemeinde
in der Schweiz,
die elektrisches Licht hatte.
Möglich machte das Johannes Badrutt.
Knapp 20 Jahre später eröffnete sein
Sohn Caspar das Badrutt's Palace.
Immer noch  d e r  Treffpunkt
des internationalen Jetsets.
Mit Suiten für gerne mal 25'000 Fr. -
pro Nacht.
Nachtskifahren, jeden Freitag,
auf der längsten beleuchteten Piste
der Schweiz.
* Sanfte, verspielte Musik *
Die Pistenfahrzeuge
sind in solchen Nächten
praktisch rund um die Uhr im Einsatz.
Ich bin die einzige Frau im Team,
aber mir gefällt es
als Frau in einem Männerteam.
Es ist schon besonders
als Frau in einem Team.
Es ist ein schöner Status.
Es sorgen sich alle um mich,
wenn ich ein Problem habe,
wird mir sofort geholfen.
Ein Mann ist eher
auf sich allein gestellt.
Über Funk sind alle Bullyfahrer
miteinander verbunden.
Das Team ist wie eine Familie.
Das ist vergleichbar.
Alle arbeiten in der Nacht.
Alle leben ein wenig
am normalen Leben vorbei.
Darum sind wir in der Nacht
schon ein bisschen eine Familie.
Erst um 4 Uhr morgens
wird Mariella heute Schluss machen.
Am Fusse des Corvatsch: Silvaplana.
Tennis- und Fussballplätze sind unter
einer dicken Eisschicht verborgen.
Wie eine leuchtende Schlange
in der Dunkelheit.
Autoscheinwerfer auf den Serpentinen
hoch Richtung Julierpass.
Die Hauptstrasse Nummer 3
führt von Castasegna
an der italienischen Grenze
im Bergell
über Chur und Zürich bis nach Basel.
* Perlende Klänge *
Inmitten der rauen Berglandschaft
auf 2'300 m Höhe: das Theater Origen.
Im roten Holzturm blickt man hinab
auf eine schwebende Bühne.
Vom Julier- Richtung Gotthardmassiv.
Die Sportarena von Flims und Laax
in der Surselva.
Der Crap Sogn Gion mit
seiner raumschiffartigen Bergstation.
Keine 60 km Luftlinie weiter
südwestlich in der Leventina: Airolo.
Die Südseite des Gotthards war
für das Schweizer Militär seit jeher
von strategischer Bedeutung.
Darum auch die vielen Festungen.
1995 kam die Kaserne Bedrina hinzu.
600 Sanitätsrekruten
sind in Airolo einquartiert.
Heute steht ein Nachtmarsch an.
Leutnant Vivien Hofer
hat das Kommando über Rekruten
aus allen Sprachregionen.
Seit ich fünf Jahre alt war,
wollte ich auch ins Militär.
Mein Vater war dort.
Dann ...
... mussten sich meine Freunde
damit beschäftigen.
Dann habe ich mich entschieden,
auch das Militär zu machen.
Vivien Hofer ist 23 Jahre alt
und befehligt bis zu 200 Rekruten.
* Rufe auf Französisch *
Wir machen es so:
Wenn der erste Lastwagen
gefahren ist, fahren wir auch.
Sie sind seit vier Wochen
in der Ausbildung
und absolvieren heute
ihre erste Nachtübung.
Einen 10-km-Marsch.
Die grösste Herausforderung
für die Truppe wird die Kälte
und der letzte Marschteil sein.
Dieser ist steil.
Wenn sie frieren und müde sind,
kann das auf die Motivation drücken.
Aber das werden wir schon auffangen.
* Hüpfende Musik *
Lastwagen übernehmen das Verschieben,
den Transport der Rekruten
zum Abmarschort.
Die meisten der angehenden Soldaten
sind junge Männer.
Doch der Anteil der Frauen
in der Schweizer Armee steigt.
Viele von ihnen
übernehmen Führungsaufgaben.
Es gilt der Grundsatz:
gleiche Leistung, gleiche Chancen.
Allumez votre lampe frontière!
Alors, bon marche!
- (Alle) Merci.
Es kommen keine dummen Sprüche.
Die Gleichberechtigung
steht an oberster Stelle.
Das gefällt mir.
Es ist eine kalte Februarnacht.
Die Vorgesetzten
begleiten den Marsch im Auto.
Filippo Boo ist Hauptmann.
Er ist verantwortlich
für die Ausbildung der Rekruten.
Nachtarbeit ist für ihn Routine.
(Italienisch)
In der Kälte der Nacht
treffen die Rekruten
auf einen ersten Verpflegungsposten.
Es gibt Tee, Obst und Schokoriegel.
Leutnant Vivien Hofer ist zufrieden.
Bis jetzt keine Zwischenfälle.
Alles läuft nach Plan.
Das sind meine Rekruten,
sie sind wie meine Kinder.
Auf den Märschen
bin ich immer etwas nervös,
ob es allen gut geht,
ob sie den Marsch absolvieren.
Ob sie überhaupt zu Ende laufen.
Wenn es Leute mit Problemen gibt,
ist man als Kompaniekommandant
mit Herz und Seele dabei.
Die Truppe
beschwört den Zusammenhalt.
* Anfeuerungsrufe *
(Italienisch)
Noch liegt ein ordentliches Stück Weg
vor ihnen,
bis zu einer Unterkunft
in einem ehemaligen Pferdestall.
Dort werden sie ein paar Stunden
ausruhen dürfen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Nördlich des Gotthards:
über dem Pilatus
ein majestätischer Blick auf Luzern.
Der Bahnhof von Luzern,
entworfen von Santiago Calatrava.
* Knall *
Der Urknall am Schmutzige Donnschtig.
Luzern im Ausnahmezustand.
Fritschi-Umzug, Güdismäntig
und Monstercorso -
für rund 200'000 Luzernerinnen
und Luzerner
sind diese sechs Tage und Nächte
der Höhepunkt des Jahres.
* Rhythmisches Trommeln *
Erst am Morgen des Aschermittwochs
findet das bunte Treiben ein Ende.
* Sanfte Musik *
Über den Pilatus Richtung Süden.
In wenigen Flugminuten
ist man im Berner Oberland.
Gadmen am Fusse des Sustenpasses
ist im Februar
Kulisse eines besonderen Spektakels:
eines Schlittenhunderennens.
Alain Hauert
nimmt schon das fünfte Mal
an der nächtlichen Gadmer Trophy
teil.
* Besänftigungsrufe *
Vor zehn Jahren
hatte ich noch Angst vor Hunden.
Heute habe ich wegen meiner
Partnerin Vivienne Schlittenhunde,
die schon von klein auf
Husky-Fan ist.
Sie kaufte den ersten Hund,
ich rutschte da rein.
Alains Partnerin, Vivienne Décorvet,
besitzt inzwischen elf Hunde
aus eigener Zucht.
Ich fuhr schon mit sieben Jahren
die ersten Kinderrennen.
Jetzt bin ich 37 und bin immer noch
Schlittenhunde-Fan.
Das ist meine Sucht, die bis
zu meinem Lebensende anhalten wird.
(Speaker) Wir wünschen all the best!
Go! Go! Go, Alain!
7 km lang ist die Strecke.
Der Fahrer, genannt Musher, lenkt die
Hunde nur mit gerufenen Kommandos.
Das Kopflicht des Mushers
weist den Hunden den Weg.
* Sanfte Musik *
Sie laufen sehr gerne in der Nacht.
Es ist ein anderes Feeling
für die Hunde als während des Tages,
auch wegen der Tiere in der Wildnis.
In der Dunkelheit
müssen sich Musher und Hunde
noch mehr aufeinander verlassen
als bei Rennen am Tag.
Die Gadmer Trophy
ist ein besonderer Wettbewerb.
Es geht nicht nur um Schnelligkeit,
sondern auch um Geschick.
Es ist ein Anlass
wider den tierischen Ernst.
Wir freuen uns an unseren Hunden,
sind draussen,
es ist Nacht und Winter -
ein toller Event.
Die Hunde erreichen bis zu 40 km/h.
Damit die Tiere fit sind,
müssen Alain und Vivienne
jeden Tag mit ihnen trainieren.
Sie können eigentlich
immer durchhalten.
Sie können bis zum Tod rennen.
Man muss sie selber bremsen,
sonst würden sie
ununterbrochen rennen.
Das ist ihre Leidenschaft.
Nach einer knappen Stunde
erreicht Alain das Ziel.
Heja, heja!
Heja, heja, das war gut.
- Das war gut.
Super, Inari.
Noch schnell die Hunde versorgen,
dann kommt der gemütliche Teil
der Nacht.
* Sanfte Musik *
Man ist in der Wildnis.
Die Stimmung ist immer cool,
weil viele Menschen hier sind.
Die Nacht-Trophy ist das Highlight
dieses Wochenendes.
* Sanfte Musik *
Seit mehr als 20 Jahren leuchtet
dieser Stern auf dem Harder Kulm.
Als vorweihnachtlicher Gruss gedacht
ist er zur Winterbeleuchtung des
Hausbergs von Interlaken geworden.
Interlaken,
ein Topspot für Touristen,
verzeichnet in guten Jahren
bis 3 Mio. Logiernächte.
Weit herum bekannt:
das Victoria-Jungfrau Grand Hotel.
* Sanfte Musik *
In der Dunkelheit
nur schemenhaft zu erkennen:
die berühmtesten drei Gipfel
der Region:
Eiger, Mönch und Jungfrau.
Das Wahrzeichen von Lauterbrunnen:
der Staubbachfall.
In der Hochsaison
ist er auch nachts zugänglich.
Auf dem Schilthorn thront die
Bergstation mit Panorama-Restaurant.
Unvergesslich:
James Bonds Verfolgungsjagden 1969
im Geheimdienst ihrer Majestät.
Unterhalb des knapp 3'000 m
hohen Gipfelrestaurants
werden auch hier Pisten präpariert.
* Instrumentalversion
der "James Bond"-Titelmelodie *
Die einzige direkte Verbindung
vom Berner Oberland ins Wallis
ist immer noch der Lötschbergtunnel.
Seit 2007
dauert die Fahrt nur noch 15 Min.
Alexander Ebener ist für das Be-
und Entladen der Züge zuständig.
Wir sind hier
quasi so etwas wie Polizisten.
Um den Verkehr zu regeln.
Man muss den Leuten zeigen,
wo sie hinfahren müssen,
obwohl alles gut signalisiert ist.
Auf der Rampe muss man die Leute ...
... instruieren.
Sonst kommt es hier nicht gut.
Sonst gibt es viel Blechschaden.
Alexander Ebener und seine Kollegen
schleusen jährlich
mehr als 1 Mio. Fahrzeuge
durch den 34 km langen Lötschberg.
Der Fahrplan ist eng getaktet.
Die Züge fahren jede halbe Stunde,
in Stosszeiten sogar alle 15 Min.
Die grosse Verantwortung
liegt im Zeitplan:
dass der Zug rechtzeitig abfährt.
Und dass die Autos richtig verladen
sind, richtig auf dem Zug stehen,
damit es keine Überbrückung gibt.
Das ist die grosse Herausforderung.
Und Kundenfreundlichkeit.
Man sollte immer ein schönes
Lächeln ... für die Kunden haben.
Heute ist Mittwoch,
da ist der Andrang nicht so gross.
Hochbetrieb
herrscht an den Wochenenden,
v.a. während der Winterferien.
Da wollen bis zu 10'000 Fahrzeuge
täglich auf den Verlad.
Alexander
arbeitet allein in der Spätschicht.
Ihm bleibt keine Zeit,
die Autos ordnungsgemäss einzuweisen,
denn er gibt auch das Signal
zur Abfahrt der Züge.
Das ist ein Wagen,
und hier sind zwei Autos drauf.
Hier hätten eigentlich
vier bis fünf Autos Platz.
Er ist allein, schau.
Der nächste ist hier.
Wenn kein Einweiser da ist, wird
keine Rücksicht genommen. Leider.
Da zählt nur, dass man
auf dem Zug ist, der Rest ... egal.
1926 wurden erstmals Fahrzeuge
durch den Lötschberg transportiert.
Alexanders Familie ist Teil
dieser Lötschberg-Geschichte.
Der Grossvater war das Vorbild.
Das hier ist mein Grossvater.
Er war Betriebsmitarbeiter der BLS.
So wurden früher die Autos verladen.
Ohne Dach.
Hier musste man mit Holzkeilen
die Autos verkeilen.
Pro Tag gab es vielleicht einen Zug.
Damals war der Autoverlad
noch rund um die Uhr in Betrieb.
Doch die Zeiten haben sich geändert.
Heute herrschen in Kandersteg
und Goppenstein 6 Std. Nachtruhe.
Durch die Automatisierung
ist alles in Spiez
und läuft ferngesteuert
von dort aus.
Das ganze BLS-Netz.
Dadurch ist in Goppenstein
niemand mehr.
Um 23.30 Uhr sind wir die Letzten,
die hier sind.
* Sanfte Musik *
Auf der Grenze zwischen den Kantonen
Bern und Wallis -
einer der magischsten Orte
der Schweiz:
das Jungfraujoch
mit der Felsenkuppe Sphinx.
Das Observatorium
liegt auf 3'571 m Höhe.
Zusammen mit der Endstation
der Jungfraubahn
Ziel von etwa 1 Mio. Touristen
jedes Jahr.
Der mächtigste Eisstrom der Alpen:
der Aletschgletscher.
Die Klimaerwärmung setzt ihm zu.
Einst lag die Konkordiahütte nur
wenige Meter über dem Gletscherrand.
Heute thront sie gut 150 m
über dem Konkordiaplatz
mit seinem rund 800 m dicken Eis.
Klima- und Gletscherforscher rechnen,
dass der Gletscher in 80 Jahren
wohl ganz verschwunden sein wird.
Die Bergkulisse im Wallis.
Umrahmt von Viertausendern
liegt Saas-Fee.
Hier gibt es noch eine der wenigen
Natureisbahnen der Schweiz.
Otto Zengaffinen ist der Eismeister.
Seit mehr als 30 Jahren.
Er kommt morgens als Erster
und geht abends als Letzter.
Seine wichtigste Aufgabe ist,
das Eis zu präparieren.
Hier passen 600 l rein.
Das reicht,
um einmal das Eis zu machen,
mit 1 mm Wasser auf dem Eis.
Genau so viel
hoble ich bei einem Durchgang ab.
Gleich viel Wasser kommt dann nach.
So habe ich stets denselben Stand.
Unter der Eisfläche
liegen ein Hartgummifeld
und mehrere Tennisplätze.
Anfang November beginnt Otto,
das Eis aufzubauen.
Schicht für Schicht.
Immer nachts, wenn es kalt ist.
Nach drei Wochen ist es dick genug,
um Regen und höheren Temperaturen
zu trotzen.
Eismachen, sagt Otto,
sei eine Wissenschaft.
Und ein bisschen Magie.
Ich passe mich der Natur an.
Die Natur kann man nicht veräppeln.
Man muss mit dem arbeiten,
was man hat.
Luftfeuchtigkeit,
Kälte, Wärme, Regen, Schnee ...
Es gibt keine Feinde.
Aber das Schlimmste ist, wenn es
drei Tage lang je 10 cm Schnee gibt.
Da kommt man nicht mehr nach.
Kaum ist das Eis bereit,
schneit es erneut.
Dann kam es auch schon vor,
dass ich Petrus
den Finger gezeigt habe.
Ist das gut? Die Maschine geht an.
Im Dorf nennen sie Otto
den Eisflüsterer.
Er mag die Kälte und die Stille.
Es ist ruhig und kalt.
Natürlich wäre ich lieber zu zweit.
Aber im Grossen und Ganzen
mache ich es sehr gerne.
Wenn ich am nächsten Tag
nach Hause gehe,
lässt mich meine tolle Frau
schlafen.
Dann kann ich es auch geniessen.
Otto ist mittlerweile 77 Jahre alt.
Das Eismachen halte ihn jung,
sagt er,
und ein Nachfolger
sei nicht in Sicht.
Seit zehn Jahren
ist es immer mein letzter Winter.
Im Frühling räume ich meinen Spind
und sage: "Jetzt ist Schluss."
Aber ich bin immer noch hier.
Bevor ich morgens um 5 Uhr
Feierabend mache,
müssen die Schläuche
entleert werden.
Sonst sind sie morgen pickelhart.
Das mache ich jetzt.
Nachher gehe ich schlafen.
Otto hofft,
dass es in der Nacht nicht schneit
und er durchschlafen kann.
Morgen macht er weiter
auf der Natureisbahn von Saas-Fee.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Die Nacht neigt sich dem Ende zu.
Zermatt erwacht.
Ein neuer Tag bricht an
in den Städten, Bergen
und Tälern der Schweiz.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Michaela Hoss - 2022